apparently shoot first and ask questions
later is the new modus operandi from the
White House after getting humiliated by
a Chinese spy balloon two weeks ago
sadly this kind of flat-footed response
it isn't limited to the sky so far there
has been no real effort to curtail the
chinese-based app Tick Tock as Chinese
hackers pose a growing threat to
Americans meanwhile in East Palestine
Ohio the administration is slow walking
FEMA assistance and pothole Pete well
he's nowhere to be found joining us now
with reaction host of the Monica Crowley
podcast Monica Crowley along with Fox
News contributor Tammy Bruce uh Tammy
let me go to you first because I got to
tell you it this is not a good look for
an Administration I know they they have
a new Chief of Staff but I'm telling you
the week could not have been worse for
the Biden Administration well and partly
that's because they were exposed right
the Chinese balloon itself we now CBS is
reporting that we saw it launch from
China and we were watching it the entire
way until it turned left when it went
over Guam and came up to to Alaska so I
don't know what's worse is that we knew
and we did nothing and allowed it to
Traverse or we didn't know but the
bottom line is is that it seems clear
that we did know and that they didn't
expect us to find out if it wasn't for
an Intrepid Billings Gazette
photographer who happened to look up and
said is that a bus or is it Superman
right I mean what is this above the in
the sky they took a picture it gets in
the Billings Gazette and it blows up
what the Biden administration had
planned which was to say nothing and and
this I think it's also not unexpected
because when we say shoot first and ask
questions later it immediately reminded
me suddenly them being trigger happy
with shooting things out of the sky
without knowing what they were reminded
me horribly of a very a deadly example
of that in Afghanistan during the
withdrawal when we killed 10 civilians
including seven children and if we were
told it was to stop another attack on
the airport and it was it was an aid
worker who was working with usaid uh
usaid agency and his family so this is
what the Biden Administration has been
doing from the beginning ranging from
the as you've noted the horrible
response when it comes to the East
Palestine train wreck but it really is a
chemical spill the lack of reaction to
that this is from Identity politics
frankly it's a narrative that matters
before governing the American people
don't matter at all this is about
maneuvering people as chess pieces and
people die as a result and our national
security clearly is at Great risk in the
meantime
I mean Monica they could not have come
up with a more convoluted story well we
can't shoot it over the land then they
do shoot it over land then they say they
don't know what the balloon is but they
do know what the balloon is it passed
over Alaska it didn't pass over Alaska I
know we may never never recover it they
bring the Senators and the house members
in for a classified briefing and every
one of them walked out of there and said
we have more questions now than ever
before
yeah you know when I and I think most
people understand this if anybody has
ever lied when you lie you got to keep
your story straight and it becomes
increasingly difficult to keep a lie
straight because you forget who you've
told and what stories that you've told
this Administration lies non-stop so
it's not a surprise that they're lying
about critical National Security issues
including involving this Chinese aerial
surveillance craft which is what it is
we can call it a cute name spy balloon
but this was a CCP pla aerial
surveillance tool they're gathering
information they are gathering
intelligence all the time about the
United States sensitive military and
nuclear sites how we react they're
constantly probing this Administration
to what end and I think that's a really
dangerous and terrifying question here
is that the CCP appears ready to move
whether it's on Taiwan whether it's on
America's interests around the World
whether it's on our homeland we don't
know but we what we do know is that they
are calculating that they have a limited
window of opportunity while we have a
thoroughly compromised American
president who is uh definitely
compromised by the CCP but is also weak
and is turning America into a lame uh
player on the global uh uh scene and so
their intent is for global domination
and we've got a president who is
completely ill-prepared and unwilling to
act to defend the Homeland and America's
interests around the world that's how
dangerous this is
well I mean you're talking about the
compromise I mean one of the obvious
questions that was thrown out Tabby to
the president listen to how he answers
well listen to this clip I don't want to
get your reaction to it
thank you very much
[Music]
there's been criticism that this wasn't
there's been criticism that this really
trying to compromise by your family's
business relationship Sir Mr President
Mr President there has been criticism
that this was an overreaction that was
done because of political pressure
off and that's the question when you
have more polite people
I mean there's the president getting the
question are you compromised and he's oh
come on man that's the answer yeah this
is you know this is what happens when
you've gotten away with so much because
you've been governing from a basement
and when you have no real care about the
actual impact and normally the media
protects them and and they still tend to
protect him you know even the news
coverage of what was happening and what
is happening in East Palestine is really
quite muted uh it because it's and
you've got Pete bootage he makes his
rounds and he's not really challenged
when he calls it a train derailment well
it was but again it's a chemical
disaster and that's affecting people's
lives so this is again an element of
what we've seen over and over and over
again with Joe Biden it's not an
accident they're not having a bad day
and when you've got you know reporters
saying are you compromised at people
what's going on here they and then they
conveniently and this is what none
Americans don't like this shooting these
things down over water the like Huron
balloon or object we believe was the one
they saw in Montana the night before and
then they just wait until they can shoot
it down and it took two shots so there
was a Sidewinder missile that went
astray because we missed an object as
far as we know that was not shooting
back there's so many questions that we
have to ask here and I trust that the
Republicans in the house are going to do
so a million dollars a half a million
dollars for each missile
a jet maybe it's the school project we
shot down but my goodness isn't this a
guy buying a Corvette because he's
trying to make up for something he
doesn't have
yeah and and Monica the idea that the
White House would not authorize a FEMA
declaration asked for by the governor of
one of the worst chemical and Spills we
still don't know the fully full extent
of it FEMA is there it's the Federal
Emergency Management agency that is not
a good look to turn down the request of
a state I mean it's just a couple miles
from Pennsylvania it's over there in
eastern Ohio but that is a really bad
look and it's not helpful to the people
who have all kinds of questions about
their health
well this is what you get when you get
America last we had America First under
President Trump and under President
Biden we've got America last and that
means Americans last I mean at the same
time that we have this ecological
catastrophe in the heartland of America
where our fellow Americans are really
suffering in terms of air quality water
quality they can't live their lives they
can't take a shower they can't drink
from the top while we have this
ecological disaster going on this
leadership is actually requesting more
money for Ukraine
so this tells you exactly how much this
White House's Administration the regime
how much they hate the American people
who do not vote for them who do not
support their agenda they show it in
their actions constantly and to deny the
state of Ohio an emergency Declaration
of catastrophe so that federal funds
which Tammy and I and you don't mind
paying for our fellow Americans when
they're facing this kind of disaster but
to deny the state of Ohio which is a red
State and it backs up to Biden's you
know home state Scranton Pennsylvania to
deny them these funds and this kind of
federal government support is absolutely
outrageous but it's a surprise nobody at
this point and in the meantime we're
paying for grief counselors for federal
workers for the Bureau of Land
Management who have emotional upset over
the destruction of the ecology and of
nature so we're willing to pay for that
but we're not willing to pay to help the
people of East Palestine are Americans
whatever their political party who are
struck by now by a man-made disaster
here
yeah
where is it where Sal go where's Al Gore
where's Greta where's Michael Moore all
of these people that were constantly
screaming about the environment climate
protecting people especially Michael
Moore in the Heartland where are these
people they're dead silent well listen
it's not a tune to the political
narrative
well and this is the problem The First
48 Hours of This Disaster are the most
imperative and and there were we pay
billions of dollars as the American
people to be right there and have that
expertise so they can support the states
the little communities like uh like an
East Palestine and they're not there it
is two weeks since it has happened now
they're going to put in a few people and
some some dollars but it's coming way
too late Monica and Tammy thank you so
much for joining us tonight hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else